what if you could make your sleep more
efficient as a sleep scientist this is
the question that has captivated me for
the past 10 years because while the
light bulb and technology have brought
about a world of 24-hour work and
productivity it has come at the cost of
our naturally occurring circadian rhythm
and our body's need for sleep the
circadian rhythm dictates our energy
level throughout the day and only
recently we've been conducting a global
experiment on this rhythm which is
putting our sleep health and ultimately
our life quality in jeopardy
because of this we aren't getting the
sleep we need with the average American
sleeping a whole hour less than they did
in the 1940s for some reason we decided
to wear it as a badge of honor
that we can get by on not enough sleep
this all adds up to a real health crisis
most of us know that poor sleep is
linked to diseases like Alzheimer's
cardiovascular disease stroke and
diabetes and if you go untreated with a
sleep disorder like sleep apnea you're
more likely to get many of these
illnesses but did you know about sleeps
impact on your mental states poor sleep
makes us make risky rash decisions and
is a drain on our capacity for empathy
when sleep deprivation literally makes
us more sensitive to our own pain it's
not so surprising that we have a hard
time relating to others and just
generally being a good and healthy
person when we're sleep-deprived
scientists are now starting to
understand how not only the quantity but
also the quality of sleep impacts our
health and well-being my research
focuses on what many scientists believe
is the most regenerative stage
sleep deep sleep we now know that
generally speaking there are three
stages of sleep light sleep rapid eye
movement or REM and deep sleep we
measure these stages by connecting
electrodes to the scalp chin and chest
in light sleep and REM our brainwaves
are very similar to our brainwaves in
waking life but our brainwaves in deep
sleep have these long bursts brain waves
that are very different from our waking
life brain waves these long burst brain
waves are called delta waves when we
don't get the deep sleep we need it
inhibits our ability to learn and for
our cells and bodies to recover deep
sleep is how we convert all those
interactions that we had make during the
day into our long-term memory and
personalities as we get older we're more
likely to lose these regenerative Delta
waves
so in a way deep sleep in Delta waves
are actually a marker for biological
youth so naturally I wanted to get more
deep sleep for myself and I literally
tried almost every gadget gizmo device
and hacked out their consumer grade
clinical grade what have you I learned a
lot and I found I really do need like
most people eight hours of sleep
I even shifted my circadian component in
order to by changing my meals exercise
and light exposure but I still couldn't
find a way to get a deeper night of
sleep that is until I met dr. Dmitry
gerashenko from Harvard Medical School
Dmitri told me about a new finding in
the literature where a lab out of
Germany showed that if you could place
certain sounds at the right time and
people sleep you could actually make
sleep deeper and more efficient and
what's more is that this lab showed that
that you actually could improve next-day
memory performance with this sound
Dmitri and I teamed up and we began
working on a way to build this
technology with our research lab
collaborators at Penn State
we designed experiments in order to
validate our system and we since
received grant funding from the National
Science Foundation and the National
Institute of Health to develop this deep
sleep stimulating technology here's how
it works people came in a lab and we
hook them up to a number of devices two
of which I have on right here not a
fashion statement when we detected that
people were in deep sleep we played the
deep sleep stimulating sound that was
shown to make them have deeper sleep I'm
gonna demo this sound for you right now
pretty weird right so that sound is
actually at the same burst frequency as
your brainwaves when your brain is in
deep sleep that sound pattern actually
Prime's your minds to have more of these
regenerative Delta waves when we ask
participants the next day about the
sounds they were completely unaware that
we played the sounds yet their brains
responded with more of these Delta waves
here's an image of someone's brain waves
from the study that we conducted see the
bottom panel
this shows the sound being played at
that burst frequency now look at the
brain waves in the upper part of the
graph you can see from the graph that
the sound is actually producing more of
these regenerative Delta waves we
learned that we could accurately track
sleep without hooking people up to
electrodes and makes people sleep deeper
we're continuing to develop the right
sound environment and sleep habitats to
improve people's sleep health our sleep
isn't as regenerative as it could be but
maybe one day soon we could wear a small
device and get more out of our sleep
thank you
[Applause]